bon moyen de lancer un tout nouveau
smartphone pujadas et le mythique cesse
de regarder c'est super intéressant vous
appuyer il souffre comme ça un pack
grand smartphone alors c'est une très
très grande diagonale de 7 pouces et au
dos vous n'avez absolument rien les
efforts à avait déjà vu avec le
médecin-chef de dessin c'est la nouvelle
porsche alors pour l'instant il
n'arrivera pas en france probablement
plus tard probablement on est à 1915
euro en 1999
très sympa jolie proposition 80 finition
singer oui je sais pas si ça pourrait
vous tendez dit vraiment aux
commentaires à presque deux mille euros
est ce que vous pourriez aller meetic 16
go allez-y jade et la recommander